[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
peter schrager the nfl network good
morning football co-host
and a senior national writer went to
emory university as emery
ever made the tournament peter the
division three team
they've had their moments but not at the
division
i am such a fool dan i was so excited to
have like a pizza
and a beer at noon eastern and watch all
the
i just found out literally this morning
like literally this morning that they're
doing this staggered thing and
i texted ian eagle i'm like what game
are you on today and he's like
dude yeah you're out of touch
how did you uh who do you have winning
by the way
uh i had my four-year-old son do my
bracket he likes maryland because they
wore yellow one time
okay that's a gutsy call but uh
wait for it yeah yeah whatever your
philosophy is
all right how would you sum up this uh
week of free agency
kind of fun like the the patriots thing
i can't talk enough about i got
belichick behind me on my screen here
i think that they zig what everyone else
zags and i'm here for it uh the salary
cap is down 15 million dollars
a lot of these teams are preparing for
it to go up 15 million so think about
that 30 million
deferential so all of them thought they
were doing one strategy let's just be
smart with our money and wait these
players out
belichick pounced it's almost like he
saw a market inefficiency
i'm fascinated to see how this works out
this is against everything he has been
about for 20 years as a head coach and
personnel man
but they broke the bank and they got
some good talent i don't know if they
got any
a plus talent but they certainly are
relevant again in the afc and i just
thought the strategy was so interesting
from belichick
is he building an offense that it suits
cam newton
yeah that i mean those tight ends that's
that's what that's telling me that's
telling me we're going to get additional
blocking
and we're also going to get that 10 to
15 yard intermediary stuff and we're not
looking for you to throw that depo
i don't know if cam newton can throw the
ball 15 yards anymore i honestly don't i
didn't see it towards the end of the
season
but when you have all these guys like
janu and then edelman
and then now you add in hunter henry who
i think could be fantastic
you've got big bodies who can run the
intermediary routes and can block so
yeah but if you have guys that like i
don't understand this why are you set at
quarterback if you've got a quarterback
who can't throw
i don't know if they think they're set
at quarterback they have a quarterback
and these guys play to his suit you know
suit his stuff so
at the the in the very near term their
offense got
significantly better over the last four
days than they were last year and
i think it's a bit of a humble pie but
like
for years belichick didn't do this and
one of the reasons why i was like you
build through the draft
you let your free agents sign elsewhere
and then you get the compensatory picks
and you get a bunch of third and fourth
round picks and we can draft a gronk or
an aaron hernandez remember
they've whiffed in the draft the last
few years with the third and fourth
round pick so essentially
he's like we're not gonna get big
compensatory picks from the free agents
that are leaving because no one really
besides joe tooney is a big name
so let's just do it let's just rip the
band-aid off and get them i just don't
know if
agalor and bourne necessarily make this
wide receivers group what they have down
in tampa bay overnight
and you got some wide receivers who are
still out there you know kenny golliday
uh smith schuster will fuller um
where do you see could they be changing
the
structure of the power structure in the
nfl
i think a lot of these guys and their
agents are waking up on a thursday
morning a little
bewildered surprised and now having to
readjust what they
expected look kenny gallaudet was
offered a really handsome two-year deal
by the lions
during the season he turned it away
because he wanted to hit free agency
his agent todd france is the same agent
as dak prescott
he said let's bet on ourselves and
you'll get more money elsewhere well i
don't know if that money's there right
now
and now kenny galladay who was viewed as
the top wide receiver talent
is having to get on a plane he's gonna
the giants want to meet him before
they do anything they want to speak with
him in person the bengals offered him
something from what i'm told
but it's a cincinnati bengals and it's a
one-year proven deal like
i think this is kind of shocking for a
lot of these wide receivers and for juju
look i got accused of of being one of
those people who was yelling at a cloud
when i was like i don't like the
tick-tock dancing before a game and i
don't
necessarily like the dancing on a logo
before you i look
everyone rocked me then in december and
was like you were being just a media
hater or whatever
juju smith schuster the line is not long
right now and i think the first
impression for a lot of these gm's is
like i don't know if i need all that it
seems like a lot
even though he's a good player he's a
great kid and he's 24 years old
so the story from ian rapport this
morning was that
the jets are a possibility and the jets
have had conversations with jude smith
schuster
i don't know if it's one of those deals
where the jets are on day three
banging down the door and being like
wait juju is available let's go get them
so
i think juju gallaudet fuller and their
agents are a little surprised and might
not have been expecting this to be the
market
arizona got older did they get better
i don't know i think so and i think it's
not because of watt and green
i think the name rodney hudson isn't a
household name but he's a 32 year old
center that the
raiders couldn't afford anymore and they
traded him 60 cents on the dollar
to to the cardinals and they know the
time is now for the cardinals
kylo murray is a running quarterback
kyler murray is one of these guys that
is going to get injured time to time if
you don't protect him it happened last
year in a week 17 when they needed him
most he wasn't available and they had to
go to a cfl
retread as their quarterback against the
rams and that must win
um so hudson protects him at the very
least
they're they're making moves they're
aggressive j.j watt aj i like even the
kicker they
got matt prater who's a reliable kicker
zan gonzalez missed a bunch last year
i appreciate teams that say i know
salary caps not ideal
but let's go spend the money and we can
make no excuses like let's bring them in
i respect that they they were a few
players away last year
they went and they at least made the
attempts to get them that nfc west
though that's that's a loaded division
peter schrager nfl network good morning
football co-host
explain to me the situation with the
bears and the seahawks that you get the
two gm's together
and you make your offer usually when you
make an offer for a house
they counter your offer and in this case
they just listened to the offer took it
back to pete carroll and then pete said
no
and then that's it why did they listen
to the bear's offer in the first place
peter
yeah so i'm looking at a billy ripken
famous card that's in front of you if
if i if i if i if i was sitting here
just on my couch or whatever and
you said uh or your agent said publicly
we would love my billy ripken card to go
to one of four cities
and one of them is where peter schrager
resides i would probably be like whoa
okay i want that billy ripken card i'm
gonna i'll call up i'll inquire
the agent mark rogers dropped this out
of nowhere
saying there are going to be four teams
that he would wave his no trade clothes
for the bears never expected russell
wilson in their plans but once that came
out
they were like let's go let's do it
let's go for it and they tried they
tried really hard and when they were all
together
out in fargo north dakota last week for
trey lance's pro day
i can tell you there were conversations
had with ryan pace and matt aggie from
the bears
with john schneider from the seahawks
and the conversations were made
and they didn't go anywhere and
schneider's like we're not trading him
so when he goes on your show dan and he
says comments about
and look russell wilson might someday be
a part of the peacock family
and he might be a great ambassador he
doesn't usually come on and say anything
controversial
we know that when he comes out and he
says his offensive line
he'd like to see more investment on your
show and make it public
people in seattle might have been like
wait what especially that offensive line
so
you put these things together chicago
had every right to go and make the most
aggressive pitch
but at the end of the day they didn't
have a quarterback to trade back to
seattle
so seattle's listening and it's okay you
can give us 16 first round picks and
khalil mack
and roquan smith and the rights to dick
butkus
and and mike singletary who's playing
quarterback next year for seattle
just didn't make sense so i get
criticized today being like oh you made
a big fuss over nothing
look when the agent comes on the record
and lists four teams and when the player
who usually says nothing
comes on the dan patrick show and says
things about his offensive line
there was something there's something
indeed there oh no it's there
absolutely but the question is why would
you listen to
the bears offer unless you want to set
the market
that this is we turned this down so you
better you better be ready to go
it feels like they have to expand their
list there of possible destinations for
russell
if he truly wants out i was told keep an
eye on free agency
will they do enough in free agency where
russell wilson goes
okay that's at least a step in the right
direction
but all right well then we're three days
in
and they've made a trade for gabe
jackson
from the raiders who it's fine while
joe tooney was just signed to a
five-year 80 million dollar deal in
kansas city rodney hudson was just
traded to protect kylo murray
and then you look at all the other top
interior offensive lineman corey linsley
was just signed by the chart like
i know that the cardinals and the
chargers and the chiefs are doing
whatever it takes to protect their
quarterbacks
i don't like hey russell wilson went
public with that offensive line talk and
all that
seahawks it's almost as if schneider and
carol like we're not going to suddenly
rip up our entire team to to go
and address your needs we're going to do
what we do and we're going to build a
football team
i'm fascinated see how it plays out but
to your point maybe the door
isn't shut on a trade just yet but the
bears one
i i rest assured the bears made every
possible offer they possibly they could
even think of
seahawks weren't making a trade with the
bears no yeah we always look at a trade
from
one angle we always go guys russ going
to the bears and then i'll go well
what's seattle getting
well they're getting draft picks those
aren't high draft picks
you're getting khalil mack and akeem
hicks okay how does that address
their their quarterbacking situation now
if you said hey the jets are giving you
the second pick overall
yep and okay you got my attention
because now i
i take zach wilson if i believe in him
now i got my quarterback rookie contract
now i'm good to go
miami i get tua and
i'm gonna get the third pick overall and
i'm gonna get devonta smith if i want
all right i like that the bears didn't
have anything to offer that would
intrigue
seattle from an offensive perspective
there so
and the worst thing that the bears had
going for them is that they had this
mediocre season and made the playoffs so
they have the 20th
yeah you know it's like it's not like
they get any accolades or any pats on
the back for going to the wild card
round and getting blown out by drew
brees in the saints i
i also will go one step further here
it's like you know
the panthers have the eighth pick the
eagles have the sixth
pick there are teams that make it really
you know interesting for a trade for a
quarterback that could maybe be the
third team in
but to your point about what are we
getting back you'd be amazed and
maybe you wouldn't because you deal with
this for 30 years
but i'm putting together trade offers
and possibilities on good morning
football to show an nfl network and i'm
like
all right so say the jets offer the
number two pick
and they offer sam darnold and they
offer quinn and williams
the amount of jets fans that jump down
your throat like we're not giving up
quinn and williams yes you will
like like we're not giving up we're good
at williams no and then you do the
dolphins and you're like all right you
give up two uh
and you also give up davonte parker and
then you also give up christian wilkins
we're not giving up all that
same thing comes from the other side of
it the fans you know they
they don't want to give up the thing so
trades are really hard and for
quarterbacks
you got to give up everything to get one
of these guys yeah and that's where
if i'm russ i don't want to go to a
bears team that just gave up all of this
to get me like that doesn't make any
sense because you're going to go and
you're going to go to a team that's
inferior
hey i get to have a say in in what we do
and i like matt and aggie's play calling
that ain't enough for me to go to the
bears i want to go to a team where
we're actually going to be good and not
give up as much as
uh you know we should uh desean watson
with what's going on now it's gonna be
harder to trade him
but do you feel like the texans now are
more likely to trade him
given what's gone on well let's see how
that all plays out
it's ugly um but his
stock if you will i almost feel like
talking about the two topics in the same
you know breath is almost minimizing
what's been accused but
the stock certainly isn't as high as it
was a week ago and you know you double
down on it
david culley the the new head coach was
doing a lot of media last week
comes across as a really likable guy a
really open and honest guy
and it was very vulnerable it was like i
want a coach desean watson i really do i
just wish
he would you know it didn't say it but
in so many words like i wish he would
give us a shot and
so you start putting these things
together and you're like all right so
they gave you
150 million dollars last year you
you know you guys won four games i don't
know what happened with what made you so
upset but the coach is saying he wants
to have you here like
i don't know at some point the tide was
going to turn against desean watson in
this conversation and be like maybe you
do give that team a shot
maybe you'd be part of the solution as
opposed to part of the problem and you
know they do have a new coach a new gm
maybe you consider that
so now i think it's really interesting
the way that the conversations about the
desean watson trade go
and i'm not sure if he's as uh you know
this
whatever it is as a trade asset if this
if this story continues to
to take on the next levels of where it
goes because it certainly makes it a lot
more complicated than it was when it was
just
hey here's a 25 year old superstar on
the on the houston texans who wants to
trade
yeah and if i'm offering something now
now i'm going to probably reduce that
you know it feels like that the value
has been reduced here
and look i don't mean to diminish what
is happening off the field but my my job
is to talk about the sports angle of
this
and that's that's exactly right and and
for a lot of these gm's
whereas they they might have been like
oh my god gung-ho deshawn watson
now maybe they see all these reports
they see it's still trending on twitter
they
read all the legal papers they're like
hey look i don't have to make this trade
i maybe it's just not worth all of my
agita and maybe it's not worth me
getting involved in this and that's
someone else's problem not mine
is gardner minshew gonna land someplace
interesting
you know i it's funny there are trade
talks going on and it
maybe mintre's got a second chapter but
i don't know if he's going to be a
starting quarterback uh in the nfl
this year what i love seeing is mike
glennon uh you know he's signing a new
deal it's like all right
these guys have lives they've got
amazing if you could be a backup
quarterback and a likable dude in the
locker room like there's a place for you
if you're willing to be that number two
chase daniel
another guy really wealthy he might be
one of the greatest
preseason quarterbacks of all time
always delivers in like the second half
of that third game
second half of that third pre-season
game chase daniel will put up numbers
he'll light it up
he will we need to we need to do fantasy
football pre-season
we should i remember uh cleo lemon
yeah the cold chargers not the dolphins
when he's on the charger
in the fourth quarter i'm like cleo
lemon love it
good luck with your bracket there i'm
going real real big on north texas
because my son likes the nickname the
mean green so let's go north texas yep
all right hey different strategies you
know
not nice you're either first place or
last place peter you're right
i'm in yeah all in uh thanks buddy
appreciate you that's uh peter schrager
host of nfl networks good morning
football that airs monday through friday
at 7
eastern you can follow him on twitter at
p
shreds